we're back and before I go any further
john ashcroft asked me to do this
he said it was distracting him
I don't know maybe he's gonna sing is
the mound our next presenters come from
Down Under
a phrase that always makes me think
passionately a Russell Crowe
from Mulholland Drive miss Naomi Watts
and I want to be very careful because I
don't want anybody getting upset with me
please also welcome Hugh Jackman
good evening it's time for the Oscars
for short films so we'll be brief
and I would repeat that for emphasis but
we don't have enough time sorry so in
the category of live-action short film
the nominees are
the accountant ray McKinnon and Lisa
bloom
puppy shop Virgil v3 griggles greatest
invention Johannes kefir a man-thing
niska's Brava shove Amir povitsky and
bogomil got Raya speed the thespians
Kalman apple and shamela back
and the Oscar goes to Ray McMillan and
Lisa Blount the accountant
Academy Awards Lorraine MacKinnon and
Lisa blunt the accountant marks mr.
McKinnon's directorial debut and his
blunts first executive producer credit
that's all we're gonna get a little
short one
we'd like to thank the Academy for this
wonderful honor in a category that still
allows for a person who's just burning
to make a movie to load a camera in the
back of his daddy's old truck gather up
some talented dreamers and do it and if
the stars align and the fates conspire
that person might find themselves
standing right here
at the good god almighty Academy Awards
I want to thank everybody who helped us
on our film especially my two partners
here my true friend Walton Goggins and
my dear and beautiful wife ELISA blunt
as wind or was seemingly closing in my
life another door opened and I only have
one person to thank for that my husband
Raymond Kenan and I just get to thank
our mama and daddy's and Eddie King
Blake Jackson and red we might be able
to pay you back thank you
you